can you touch on briefly what those
eight elements are sure and you know and
I'll remind you that folks can also
download the forms and themselves from
my website Jill Chamberlin calm so you
can see it for yourself but I'll point
out what the elements are so I do have a
few moments in time and byte moments in
time I'm talking about the first scene
and the last scene so we're going to
identify in the first scene what a
character wants and then we're gonna
have a next moment that identify is what
I call the point of no return this is
the big event it's gonna push us into
the main part of the story it's the
event that makes this movie this movie
everything else on here is internal to
the character the point of no return is
the one moment and it's external to the
character it's the one thing that has to
happen to them
so so we're talking about Groundhog Day
right so the the point of no return is
when he wakes up and discovers it's the
same day again right and it should feel
like it's this moment makes this movie
this movie without that scene you
wouldn't have the movie Groundhog Day
right it's absolutely essential so it's
important like moment like that that's
gonna drive the rest of the story it's
also external you notice it wasn't the
point of no-return is never somebody
decides to do something there's an
element of fate that is involved when
we're looking at the point of no return
so of all the elements it's the one
thing that's external that had to happen
to him he could have not had that happen
it woke enough and it was February 3rd
and then this movie wouldn't be this
movie but for whatever reason he woke up
and it was February 2nd all over again
that's outside of his control if we were
going to look at the movie Tootsie
sometimes people say oh the point of no
return is when he goes to audition for
the part that's a choice right so the
point of no-return needs to be external
to the character so I would not identify
it as he goes to audition what and what
you want to identify is the moment
outside of his control so the part where
ever
thing really changes is when so he could
have blown that audition and he almost
blows that audition he comes very close
to blowing it but the female producer
likes him right and at one point she
says I like him I like her we're gonna
hire and she leans over and says you got
the part I'm sending the contract to
your agent that's the point of no return
that because that moments outside of his
control right that would had nothing to
do with his choice he could have blown
that audition he almost did blow that
audition but that's the moment boom now
or in the movie known as Tootsie what
another thing I like to think of a great
example of this is the differences but
going from act 1 and act 2 is the Wizard
of Oz Wizard of Oz act 1 it's a black
and white point of no return is she
thinks that a tornado has lifted her
house up and dumped her in the land of
Oz and boom weren't Technicolor we want
that feeling when we enter act 2
we're in a whole new world wait in
Kansas anymore right so it's a whole new
world they're facing it's one thing
Michael Dorsey decides to audition one
day as a woman it's another thing he's
got to fool everybody 24/7 into thinking
he's a woman that's the main story or in
Groundhog Day
he's now trapped in a cycle where every
day is grandma day that's the main part
of the story so there are two kinds of
stories I talk about in the book comedy
and tragedy and these are not these
definitions don't come from Joe blame me
if you don't like them they're from
Aristotle these are the original
academic definitions of comedy and
tragedy so when I say comedy I'm not
talking about a haha comedy I'm talking
about an Aristotelian comedy and so in
Aristotelian comedy according to
Aristotle by definition is where we have
a protagonist who overcomes a flaw so
flaws can be the next element I'm going
to talk about and that there they're
going to go through change and then
eventually they're going to have a happy
ending
structurally we also have tragedies a
tragedy is going to be the opposite so
we have the same set up we have the
character wants something they get it in
a point of no return but instead of
going down down down
then coming up and having happy ending
we're gonna go in the opposite direction
they're gonna go up up up up before they
come down and have their sad ending
95% of stories are going to be comedies
by the way oh yeah at least 95 percent
and by the way this applies both to
feature film and also to episodic
television episode episodic TV works
structurally just like little each
episode is the like a little mini
feature film they have all of these
eight elements just like you find in a
feature film forgive me sorry for
interrupting but us who then the tragedy
it doesn't necessarily mean that like a
death occurs it just means that they
don't change is that right that's right
absolutely I'm sad ending oh okay so
that they should you know it they have
an unhappy ending typically but it is
and it's not just an unhappy ending you
know the way we colloquially say that oh
that's tragic in life it probably is not
the same as a tragedy in Aristotelian
sense because you might just say
something sad happens to people who have
a sad ending that's that's not as
structurally a tragedy structurally a
tragedy is because of their own flaw so
it would have to be their flaw
contributes in some way to their
downfall
so they fail to change from that flaw
and that that's part of the downfall and
and so when we're looking at the
protagonist as the the backbone there
are other elements of the story but the
nutshell we're looking at the
protagonist as the the main backbone
structurally to structure everything
around it yeah and then like I said
another major part of it was the flaw
what's the carrot the flaw is really the
DNA of the whole story it's a good
strong flaw as a writer as one of your
best tools to make sure your story is
strong because if you don't give your
character a strong flaw you're not
really giving them anywhere to go that
change is what the story's really about
so if we took Sunset Boulevard we know
what Norma Desmond her flaws are but the
screenwriter what were his flaws he was
desperate he was too naive he was
tricking her uh yes so he's the
protagonist and yeah is that he's
cynical right he's cynical he is
just a no-good writer he's always
putting himself down he's putting down
you know that voiceover that's one of
the purposes of the voiceover so for us
to hear that very cynical voice he has
where he talks about when he's reading
Norma's screenplay and he says you know
it's amazing just how bad how bad bad
writing can be right that's all
happening in voiceovers that cynical
voiceover that cynicism is the part in
that part of him that refuses to find
hope that life could be different that
actually maybe he could find actual true
love right he starts to think he's
falling in love but that cynical voice
kicks up and gets in the way he could
have been happy he could have walked
away that's what makes a perfect tragic
figure right it's he's not a victim of
circumstances it's his own flaw that is
his downfall he could have walked away
she you know the love interest is when
he brings her to the house you know she
keeps saying I've not seen any of this
she's willing to completely forgive him
for his sordid situation let's just go
let's just leave he won't let her he
won't let her do that he forces her to
see it and then pushes her away so that
cynicism and and that cynicism the same
thing that gets him to tell Norma
revealed to Norma that where the truth
about her fan letters right those call
the fan letters she's getting are
actually being written by her ex-husband
who's the the live-in servant now right
and that and that the sessile demon
DeMille wasn't coming to see her he just
wanted the car right he still could have
survived he lost the girl but he could
have survived he could have walked out
of the door flying but he had to rub
that into some Norma Desmond's face and
that's when Norma kills him right can't
just let him walk away that's why she
shoots him in the back so if he hadn't
done that if he just said goodbye took a
suitcase and gone he would have lived
it's that that tragic flaw of cynicism
that he just can't believe that the
world could be kind enough to allow him
to have love and hope even though
everyone you know he's been giving every
opportunity of that he's got this you
know this wonderful girl who's
completely forgives him this sordid
situation and
wants to be with him despite everything
he won't have it and the fact that the
film opens with the ending hmm is that
is that something that we should be
aware of I mean it does it takes a
skilled writer to be able to get a
skilled writer yeah
well it's great when you can have a
beginning and ending image that relate
to one another I mean this uses actually
it's a very popular device now in
television I think Oh Stu Sunset
Boulevard the flash-forward which was
pretty unique in 1950 when Sunset
Boulevard was created it was kind of an
anomaly right where we had it broke all
the rules we have a narrator we have a
dead narrator and we have a story that's
in flashback those are kind of three
things you know then screenwriting
one-on-one they'll kind of warn getting
screenwriters not to do doesn't mean you
can't do them because look how genius it
is in Sunset Boulevard problem is it's
hard to live up to something as well as
Sunset Boulevard does but the
flash-forward device of having is become
I think a really popular advice a device
for using for television in that in
television sometimes you are has a
slower pace at that point of no-return I
was talking Matt happens in the feature
film close to the 25 percent mark in the
running time feature film sometimes it
happens a little bit later I mean I'm
sorry in episodic television it happens
a little later sometimes because we're
doing so much world building we're
building you know in a pilot episode for
an entire 10 10 hour series this whole
world so sometimes it happens almost
close to 50 percent and in the running
time can we continue on with the eight
critical story elements yeah so the
story elements the next important thing
to talk about when I talk about the
point of no return in the point of no
return the character gets something they
want they also get something they don't
want and that's gonna be what I call the
catch so get what you want but with the
catch
so Michael Dorsey gets a part but he's
gonna have to dress up as a woman in
ground
de Phil Connors only has to spend 24
hours in Punxsutawney that was just want
but the catch is it's actually gonna be
the same 24 hours done over and over
again so the catch is attached so it's a
problem we can't just give our character
what they want because that deflates
conflict so you're giving them something
that they want along with something they
don't want and the catch is also could
be said to be the perfect test of their
flaw so the flaw and you know Phil
Connors flaw is that he's a self centric
this is the that's the catch being that
he's going to stuck spending the same
same day over and over again it's the
perfect test of someone who spa is that
they're self-centered in a comedy it's
gonna end in a happy ending but they're
gonna go down down down down before
because you've got to hit rock bottom
before you can make a change so it keep
in mind in your typical haha comedy and
your typical ha ha comedy is an
Aristotelian comedy it's down down down
now we're laughing as bad things are
happening to the protagonists they are
not laughing they're not having a good
time in act 2 of a comedy so that
they're going to go down down now until
they're gonna hit rock bottom what I
call their crisis the crisis has two
requirements one is it's their absolute
lowest place and then it is the other
requirement is that the opposite of the
want actually Groundhog Day has a really
interesting one in that he's actually
finally spent after being stuck there he
finally tells the truth to Rita the love
interest about what's going on and they
actually have kind of a wonderful day
together but it ends in this very
bittersweet moment where they're falling
asleep and he's says and the terrible
worst part is tomorrow
you're gonna think I'm a jerk again and
what is wonderful about it is this
wonderful irony and that's what we're
setting up with the crisis being the
opposite this irony he only wanted to
spend 24 hours and puck so tiny how he
wishes the day could last forever
because tomorrow she'll think he's a
jerk again so we're sending this
delicious irony
there then the next thing we're going to
identify in the nutshell is we're now
entering back three the beginning of act
3 is the climax of your movie and the
operative word that we're going to use
though is the climatic choice at the
heart of a true climax your protagonist
is making a difficult decision
so in Groundhog Day his choice is to
start stop to stop fighting it to accept
that he's there and start trying to live
every day for the fullest and so he
becomes a really good person he starts
you know doing nice things and saving
the day and doing thinking of others
because what's the point in living and
trying to have short-term gratitude he's
got to find a different experiment with
a different way of living so he actually
starts becoming this town hero of this
person who's that known as this good guy
because he's got nothing better to do
and then finally break some free of the
curse and in the final step the final
step is the very last structural element
timewise the very last scene of the
movie
and now the characters gonna come to
full circle so if his flaw was that he
was self-centered he's come full circle
towards opposite strength that he now is
selfless and right because he's been
doing these things for everybody in the
town of Punxsutawney and he wakes up
that final day and he's actually it's
become February 3rd he's free of the
curse and he actually wants to stay so
those are the eight structural elements
and so like I said it's not just moments
in time this is not a beat sheet method
they are what's important is the glue
it's the the structure that holds these
pieces apart it's the connection between
these parts these are not isolated
moments in time and this is a real easy
way for writers they can use it with
they download the worksheets from my
website I also use them in my workshops
and in my private consultation we can
see right on the piece of paper what's
working what's not and if it's not
working how to adjust it by seeing that
it fits you
what do we need to change in order to
meet the requirements in order to tell a
story effectively
you